You can edit pending or booked meetings
in TungleMe. Here's how. First, make
sure you're on home in the top menu.
Then, select manage meetings from the
left. Here, you'll see a list of your
pending and booked meetings.
Let's start with a pending meeting. We
select the event and see our editing
options below. If you simply want to
cancel the meeting, click cancel.
If you want to make changes, click edit
this meeting.
Here you'll see your editing options.
You can change the meeting subject, add
or remove invitees, or change your
proposed times.
Let's add some new times to our proposed
ones.
Once you're happy with your changes,
click save changes.
Now let's try a booked meeting. We go
back to manage meetings
and select the meeting from the list.
Here your editing options are to cancel
the meeting, change the date or time,
change the location,
or add or remove invitees.